las imágenes de soldados brasileños
desmantelando los campamentos de los
simpatizantes de bolsonaro son parte del
retrato del día después de la conmoción
social y política que representó la toma
de las sedes de los poderes del estado
en la capital estas tiendas de campaña
habían sido instaladas hace 70 días
frente al cuartel general del ejército
en Brasilia en rechazo a la victoria
electoral de Lula da Silva
toque
por favor
[Música]
un asalto que se considera como el peor
ataque a las instituciones estatales de
Brasil desde su regreso a la democracia
en la década de 1980 los poderes de la
República Defensores de la democracia y
de la carta constitucional de 1988
rechazan los actos terroristas
vandálicos criminales y golpistas que
tuvieron lugar ayer domingo por la tarde
en Brasilia el país necesita normalidad
respeto y trabajo por el progreso y la
justicia social de la nación los
radicales afines a bolsonaro causaron
daños en las sedes del supremo tribunal
de Justicia del Congreso y en el Palacio
de plan alto Aunque hubo destrozos de
equipos informáticos obras de arte y
parte de los inmobiliarios en la sede
judiciales y el legislativo el despacho
presidencial no fue invadido pues está
protegido con vidrios blindados
creo que las manifestaciones Son
innecesarias son un ataque contra la
democracia un ataque contra la población
brasileña y de ninguna manera es una
forma de libertad de expresión
creemos que la Corte Suprema tiene que
ver con algo que está pasando creemos
que nos robaron en las urnas un
presidente ladrón que le robó al país
regresa para la cena del crimen para ser
reelegido y ahí está siendo presidente
según analistas los recientes sucesos
socavarían La frágil confianza en el
mercado de Brasil mientras Lula ha
prometido llevar ante la justicia a los
responsables del asalto